-My first guest tonight is an
Emmy-nominated actor.
He stars in "This is Us", which
airs Tuesdays at 9 PM on NBC.
Everyone, please welcome
Milo Ventimiglia!
Come on! [ Laughs ]
Look at you, man!
That's what I'm talking about.
See.
-What's up, man?
-Come on, buddy.
I appreciate you coming back to
the show.
Last time you were on the show,
I don't know if you remember
this, I actually gave you
my wife's phone number by
mistake.
-How can I forget?
How can I forget
when anybody gives me their
wife's phone number?
-[ Laughs ]
We were talking and
I wanted to see if you had
a picture of you.
-I was Evel Knievel.
-So I love Evel Knievel,
and it was you dressed up --
it was a screen test for
Evel Knievel,
and you're like, "I'll send it
to you, but don't show it."
And I go, "Yeah,
because it's us."
I go, "Great," and I couldn't
remember my number,
so I go, and I just rattled off
my number,
which I thought was mine,
but it was my wife's.
And it halfway through --
-And so,
I sent -- yeah, so I send the
photo of me, full dressed --
this is like, my camera test of
Evel Knievel.
Not test -- like, we were
two days away from filing.
I was blonde, I was
hairy-chested, I was everything.
And yeah, I didn't put anything.
I just sent the photo.
Yeah.
-And then I got the,
"Who is this?"
-[ Laughs ] I'm sorry.
Oh, yeah.
My wife was laughing about it
afterwards,
I was like, "I'm sorry, I just
gave Milo Ventimiglia
your phone number."
That's so weird.
But anyways, we're big fans at
the house, so...
-Yeah. Yeah. I'm sure
it went over great.
-Is this your office?
Or is this --
Where --
-Yeah, this is my office
at home in Los Angeles.
I'm just, you know...
Got some artwork on the walls,
some Michael Muller, some stuff.
Just kinda hanging out.
There's things on, like,
every wall.
-I'm looking at one sign that
I can see
in the upper left-hand corner,
because you know I'm a fan
of yours since "Gilmore Girls",
and it says...
-Oh, yeah. Yeah, right here.
-"I love..."
"I love Dean?"
-It says, uh...
-[ Laughs ]
-"I love Dean 4 Ever."
-And that was the certificate
that you get
when you're nominated for
an Emmy.
-Oh, my gosh! Is that rubbing it
in his face?
What is that?
[ Laughs ]
-No, no. Not at all.
I mean, you know, Jared and I
are really good friends
and I made the sign for some
photograph that was --
somebody was looking for online
or something,
and so I made the sign,
and after I made it,
I just said, "Well, let me just
hang onto this,
because this is cool, and I
literally just kind of stuck it
right onto my Emmy notification
that was, you know --
hanging on my wall.
-It just happened to be there.
Yeah, just, no big deal.
It just happened to be there.
-Yeah, no big deal.
[ Laughter ]
-But I want to talk about
"This Is Us."
But I also want to thank you for
doing the stuff you do
for Red Nose Day
on NBC's --
-Yeah.
-It's a big deal,
and man, you've been with them
for a couple years now,
doing some good work.
-Yeah, I mean, you know, I've
been in the NBC family
for a very long time, and NBC
has always supported
Red Nose Day, so, you know,
in 2019 --
It's wild, I keep thinking 2019
was last year, but it wasn't.
-Yeah, I know.
-But in 2019, I got a chance to
actually go and see
how the donations were
benefiting these kids
in pretty impoverished places.
And, yeah, we were in Kenya,
and seeing kids getting
inoculated
for, like, the very, very simple
sickness and disease
that kids shouldn't have to
deal with, but, you know,
they're in bad situations.
I really was able to see
first-hand what the organization
was doing to better the lives of
these kids.
-Well, thank you for doing that.
-I'm still involved with them.
Yeah.
-I want to talk about
"This Is Us."
You never tell me what's going
to happen,
which is, I understand, but
my question for you
is, do you know
what you're doing?
-This year?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, do I know what I'm doing.
-No, I mean, you definitely know
what you're doing.
But...
-Usually,
Dan Fogelman, he'll come to set
-- and this is the difference
between, let's say, COVID set
versus normal filming set.
In a COVID set, Fogelman
doesn't visit,
so we don't get that sitting
around the campfire,
Dan, having just walked out of
the writer's room,
saying, "You guys want to know
what happens in the next
7 or 8 or 9 episodes?"
So, we don't really have that
this year,
so I'm kind of, like,
in the dark.
-I know that next season is
supposed to be
the final season.
The series finale.
-That's what we're hearing,
yeah.
-Yeah. So, do you know anything
about that?
Or is this the way --
-Oh yeah, totally.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, of course you do.
I do want to show a clip --
here's Milo Ventimiglia
in tomorrow night's episode of
"This Is Us."
Take a look.
♪♪
-Hey, man.
-Hey.
-Hey, so I got
the hot chocolate.
-Uh-huh.
-I got the corn syrup
for the candy apples,
and I bought every box
of string lights they had at the
hardware store.
-What a guy.
-Hey, do me a favor
and look at this.
I mean, did I get these letters
even?
-Yeah.
You spelled "carnival" wrong.
[ Laughs ] I'm kidding.
No.
It looks great, man.
-Great's not good enough,
Miguel.
I need this proposal
to be perfect.
-Jack, you are recreating
your first date with Rebecca
in her apartment.
It's exactly the kind of
romantic gesture that makes
other guys hate you.
-Come on, other guys
don't hate me.
-Yeah, they do.
-[ Laughs ]
-No, they don't.
We love you.
Hey, you got to give my best to
Mandy as well,
because I know she's a new mom
and that's so cool
We love her.
-It's exciting.
She actually -- baby Gus was set
the other day, last week --
it was exciting.
It was exciting to see her
as a mom. I mean, we've been
playing parents for so long,
but, like -- yeah, she's a mom.
She's a real mom.
-[ Laughs ] That's fantastic.
Give her my best.
Milo Ventimiglia, everybody!